tenemos aquí la función f x igual a
logaritmo natural de la raíz cuadrada de
x y lo que queremos hacer es encontrar
la derivada de f y la clave para
encontrarla es darnos cuenta que f se
puede ver como la composición de dos
funciones así es que vamos a hacer un
diagrama donde eso se vea muy claramente
a ver qué es lo que está pasando aquí si
tomamos una equis y se la damos a esta
función que es lo primero que hacemos
bueno pues le sacamos la raíz cuadrada
si tomamos una equis y se la damos a la
función f lo primero que estamos
haciendo en realidad es dársela a la
función que saca la raíz cuadrada de x
tenemos aquí una función que lo que hace
es sacar la raíz cuadrada de la entrada
que le demos entonces cuando a esta
función le damos una equis como entrada
nos regresa como salida
de equis y luego qué es lo que sucede
ene efe bueno ya que tenemos la raíz
cuadrada de equis sacamos logaritmo
natural y eso lo podemos ver como otra
función que lo que hace es sacar el
logaritmo natural de la entrada que le
demos y en estas funciones estoy
utilizando estos cuadrados para
representar a la entrada que le damos a
la función así es que si a esta función
le damos como entrada la raíz de x lo
que nos regresa es el logaritmo natural
de la entrada pero la entrada es la raíz
cuadrada de x lo cual es exactamente
igual a fx entonces ya escribimos a efe
x como la composición de dos funciones
porque f x la podemos ver como la
composición de estas dos funciones
todo esto es efe
v x aquí podemos ver claramente que es
la composición de dos funciones
tomamos una entrada se la damos a esta
otra función y la salida se la damos a
otra función que nos produce la salida
de la función f a esta función de aquí
le podemos llamar la función y entonces
tenemos esta función de x igual a la
raíz cuadrada de x y entonces tomamos la
salida de esa función y se la damos como
entrada a esta otra función a la que le
podemos llamar be y que hace la función
be pues toma el logaritmo natural de la
entrada que le demos en este caso cuando
tenemos esta efe estamos tomando la
función b pero tomando como entrada la
raíz de x pero eso es sólo en este caso
particular en el que estamos
construyendo a fx a b le podemos dar
cualquier entrada pero si le damos como
entrada la raíz
x nos da como salida el logaritmo
natural de la raíz de x pero si lo
queremos escribir en términos generales
podemos escribir de de equis b en x-men
t el logaritmo natural de x ahora
regresando por acá
fx es igual a logaritmo natural de la
raíz de x o sea que f de x es igual a b
que es el logaritmo natural evaluada en
o de x porque v x es la raíz de x
así es que f es la composición de estas
dos funciones lo cual puede ser muy útil
para encontrar la derivada de f porque
sabiendo esto la regla de la cadena va a
ser muy útil para encontrar la derivada
de f
y la regla de la cadena nos dice que f
prima de x es igual a la derivada de la
función exterior de prima evaluada en la
función interior y de x
la derivada de la función de adentro o
sea por prima de x y ahora lo único que
nos falta es evaluar estas expresiones
pero como hacemos eso bueno pues
regresemos por acá
tomamos esta función y la derivamos
prima de x es igual a la derivada de la
raíz cuadrada de x pero aquí para que
las cosas sean más fáciles es bueno
recordar que la raíz cuadrada de x es
igual a x elevado a la potencia un medio
y entonces simplemente podemos utilizar
la regla de las potencias para las
derivadas tenemos un medio por x a la 1
medio menos 1 pero un medio menos 1 es
simplemente menos un medio y listo ya
terminamos con esta ahora encontramos b
prima de x y bueno la derivada del
logaritmo natural de x es simplemente 1
/ x
esto ya lo vimos en algunos otros vídeos
pero aquí ya sabemos cuánto es su prima
de x ya sabemos cuánto es de prima
evaluada en x pero nos falta saber
cuánto es de prima evaluada en de x de
prima evaluada en de x la podemos
encontrar muy fácilmente simplemente
tenemos que poner y de x siempre que
tengamos una x entonces b prima evaluada
en v x es igual a 1 entre q de x lo cual
es igual a 1 entre v x es simplemente
raíz de x los pies que ponemos por aquí
raíz de x entonces este pedazo de aquí
ya lo encontramos de prima de v x es uno
entre la raíz cuadrada de x
esta otra parte de aquí prima de x
también ya la calculamos la tenemos por
aquí un medio por x a la menos un medio
ahora esto de tener x elevado a la
potencia menos un medio lo podemos
escribir mejor como aquí tenemos un
medio y x elevado a la potencia menos un
medio lo podemos escribir como uno entre
x elevado a la potencia un medio lo cual
también es igual a un medio por uno
entre la raíz cuadrada de equis o sea
uno entre dos por la raíz cuadrada de x
entonces esto es igual a empezamos por
aquí con mi prima bv x que ya vimos que
es uno entre la raíz de x y nos falta
multiplicar por el rectángulo naranja o
prima de x 1 /
2 por la raíz cuadrada de equis y esto a
cuánto es igual bueno a estas alturas es
simplemente álgebra tenemos aquí 1 entre
2 y la raíz cuadrada de x por raíz
cuadrada de x es simplemente equis y
listo la derivada del logaritmo natural
de la raíz cuadrada de x se simplifica a
1 entre 2x por aquí hice este diagrama
de las funciones para que vayas
entrenando ese músculo en tu cerebro que
te ayuda a detectar cuando una función
es la composición de dos funciones y
también para que se entienda un poco
mejor todas estas expresiones que puedes
ver en tus libros de texto de cálculo o
en tus clases pero conforme obtengas un
poco más de práctica vas a poder hacer
todos estos cálculos directamente en tu
cabeza sin tener que escribir todo esto
y muy pronto vas a llegar a un punto en
el que veas ok
f x es igual a el logaritmo natural de
la raíz cuadrada de x
y eso lo podemos ver como una
composición de funciones como un ave de
o de equis entonces lo que necesito
hacer es tomar la derivada de la función
exterior evaluada en la función interior
y nosotros ya sabemos que la derivada
del logaritmo natural de algo con
respecto a ese algo es simplemente 1
entre ese algo y eso es justo lo que
tenemos aquí lo que hicimos por acá de
hecho puedes pensar cuánto sería la
derivada del logaritmo natural de x pues
sería 1 / x 0 en realidad aquí nosotros
no estamos evaluando en x estamos
evaluando en raíz de x entonces la
derivada va a ser 1 / raíz de x así es
que aquí lo que hacemos es tomar la
derivada de la función exterior con
respecto a lo que tenemos adentro pero
luego nos falta multiplicar por la
derivada de lo de adentro
de la función interior con respecto a
equis y eso es esta parte de acá y listo
así terminamos